i love tailoring it's true i have been
in costume houses
well basically my first costume was a
diaper so not a lot of tailoring there
but i have i've been in costume houses
my entire life
and i have learned about tailoring and
alteration from these seamstresses it's
just
the greatest education i could have ever
hoped for
and i want to share some of that wisdom
that i've learned
in a new segment we're calling tinker
taylor shoulder pad
that's right we're taking a serious
movie and
making a play on the name and it's about
creating an illusion for every
body type that's empowering and makes
you look forward to getting into
the clothes that actually elongate
and accentuate the features on your body
that you're most proud of
and altering the features that you don't
love as much
and making them look more to your liking
because you can
you can create extraordinary illusions
and this is a segment
about how to take your everyday look and
turn it into something really special
tailor-made just for you so a pair of
twins wrote to us who are having trouble
getting a little suit
to fit them just right all right let's
meet one of them now
it's my friend shaunie where are you
shani
all right you're looking amazing now let
those pants drop that's right
shawnee this is how you got the suit
what are your biggest issues with that i
love the color
but it's way too long i'm on a little on
the shorter side
so the pants are way too long i think
the arms are too long and it just feels
a bit
boxy so when i look at this silhouette
and suits are so in
right now that is the biggest trend i
think you picked a great suit
beautiful color and ironically that 80s
boxy shape
is what's on trend right now okay so how
do we make it work
for you i think this right here
gives kind of a schlumpy look it's not
cute it's a little masculine
i don't like it i'm going like is there
a tie here i want to do
i want to add an accessory i want to
close it up i want to do something so
let's focus there
also you want the boxy shape
i want to go right in here and we're
going to create a dart
now a dart goes from basically these two
areas so you want darts right here
that's going to take it in and give you
a waist
right but you want shoulders and you
want a booty
all right then let's attack the pants
now you preferred a long look instead of
a tapered look anything to make me look
taller
exactly all right so we're gonna put a
heel in here we're gonna drop the back
of this pant and we're gonna buttercup
it up like that
okay now the length of the jacket you
have
if you get a longer leg this is going to
be better because you elongate
you get all of this more leg you can
afford this length okay
now i want to focus on again if you're
not going to show some foot and ankle
you got to show skin somewhere let's
focus on the forearm
it's my favorite thing to feature at 46.
i'm like
i give good forearm now i want to bring
out your twin sister
okay because we made these changes on
her
shay will you come on out here
say you look like you're feeling it i am
i love it it's so much better
so much better the heel makes me look
taller
the pant leg is the perfect length and
the sleeves are just
to die for you now
please uh stand next to each other
because i want to show
stand right next to each other because
you're safe and you're in a pod look at
how much taller
you're giving forearm the jacket length
totally works we've taken it in in the
darts
you've given yourself a cute preppy
collar i'm still seeing neck and because
i see forearm right next to it
i'm seeing skin you're giving toe
cleavage it looks so perfect the
pants are at an angle dragged all the
way to the back
but lifted in the front i think you guys
look so good i'm loving it thank you i
love it
thank you what do you guys think i love
it it's
so much better we got our easter outfit
yeah ready to go
oh my gosh you guys have to wear this
for easter
and we'll get yours done as well now a
recommendation i have
is listen you could go to a tailor
now that's going to be a little more
expensive but you can also
look at your local dry cleaner you'll
notice they have signs in the window
that say tailoring and usually those are
a little
more affordable so look around your
neighborhood and see where
a resource that fits your budget is and
i just want to thank
shawnee and such a good time doing this
with you
thank you so much thank you you're both
so beautiful inside and out and now you
have an
on point on trend suit to show off
you